well let's get more now on another story
in the courts that
labor has agreed to pay substantial
damages to seven whistleblowers over
defamatory and false allegations made
against them following a bbc
panorama investigation in which they
appeared on
anti-semitism well mark lewis is
a partner in the law firm patron law
representing the seven labor
whistleblowers and he joins us now on
the phone
uh mr lewis can you uh give us the
details of this agreement please
well the agreement settled cases the
the panorama program actually was labor
anti-semitic
and what happened was labour at the time
set out a a a campaign that
really to make a statement to discredit
the whistleblowers
disgruntled former employees and to
blame the presenter john ware as being
all sorts of things islamophobic cassius
etc in order to discredit the program
and to distract from what it was saying
today they came to court and they
apologize and retracted
exactly what they said and agreed to pay
substantial damages
of course this is a labour party with a
very different leadership from the
corbyn era
really admitting mistakes about the
previous management
well well there is an element of a new
room
trying to source out what's happened but
this relates to
what happened in the past and
unfortunately it's still um
it's the first battle of many battles to
undermine and to to exactly say
what happened rather than um the
falsities they've been
put out even as recently as the leaked
labour report
which makes um the whole issue of people
which are fault and which have to be
challenged in the courts
has this um payment of damages been
accompanied by
uh the uh full apology that the
seven have also been wanting
yes i mean they've not just apologized
to the whistleblowers but they've also
apologized to john ware
for undermining his journalism and the
questions he asked he said it was
effectively the trumpian fake news
and this has been challenging the court
and the labour party
has accepted that what was said was not
faked at all
just finally could you tell us a little
bit more about who these
whistleblowers are and what uh if
anything they've said to you they plan
to do with this
payment to them well
you know there are people who took on a
job
because they love the labour party
people who worked
in the labor party that they were
swamped with complaints not just
of anti-semitism but complaints and
misogyny
etc having to deal with them and at the
same time
having to deal with a uh faction
uh dispute to them saying that we want
to deal with these complaints we want to
deal with them properly
people were people would push to the
very edge
of stress and you know one of the
whistleblowers gave evidence
in the panorama of being very close to
taking his own life because of the
amount of
attacks that they were being put to
mr lewis thank you very much indeed uh
for joining us
mark lewis there lawyer for the seven
labour whistleblowers who've received
damages and apology from the labour
party today
following their participation in the
program on anti-semitism